[Music]
this factory makes chocolate in various
forums and sells it to companies which
manufacture chocolate products for
retail sale it also supplies chocolate
components such as cocoa powder and
cocoa butter most of the coca beans
arriving here come from West Africa
which grows 70% of the world's crop a
conveyor belt moves them through a
cleaning system a series of SIVs that
screen out twigs stones and other debris
next stop is a micronized revolving drum
that heats the coca beans to loosen
their shells then they enter a shell
removing machine called a winnower
inside successive rakes drag the beans
across screens pulling off large pieces
of shell then a vacuum sucks away the
remaining smaller pieces removing the
shell exposes the inside of the coca
bean which is called the nib the factory
will roast the nibs to develop their
flavour 50 plus percent of the nib is
fat which is cocoa butter to make
chocolate they'll combine processed nibs
cocoa butter and sugar along with milk
powder if they're making milk chocolate
first the factory processes the nibs by
grinding them the heat and friction
activate the cocoa butter producing pure
liquid chocolate called chocolate
liqueur the factory extract some of the
cocoa butter to sell it separately as
chocolate making ingredient and to use
for in-house chocolate production along
with other ingredients in various
proportions the dark chocolate recipe
for example calls for more chocolate
liqueur sugar and cocoa butter but no
milk powder the recipe for unsweetened
chocolate contains no sugar
the mixer blends the ingredients to the
consistency of a very thick cake batter
the flavor is fine by this point but the
coarse texture needs to be smoothed out
so the chocolate moves to a refining
machine passing between a set of five
rollers that reduce the particle size so
much so that within just minutes the
chocolate leaves the refiner as a fine
dry powder but now it needs to be real
iqua fide so the next stop is a machine
called a conch the friction and heat
once again activate the cocoa butter
returning the powder to a liquid state
at this point they add more cocoa butter
enough to reduce the viscosity to the
exact thickness they need just a bit for
example if they're making chocolate
chips or much more if they're making a
thin chocolate coating for chocolate
chips the conch feeds a machine called a
drop depositor as the name implies it
deposits drops of chocolate onto a
conveyor belt the nozzle trays are
interchangeable so the machine can be
set up to produce various sizes of chips
discs or other shapes the chocolate
chips still warm and soft enter a
cooling tunnel traveling for about five
minutes through several temperature
zones which vary between thirty and
fifty degrees Fahrenheit
by the time the chips exit the tunnel
they're hard
a conveyor belt then takes them through
a metal detector a standard food safety
precaution the factory also produces
10-pound ball format chocolate bars but
depositor fills bar shaped plastic molds
the conveyer transfers them to an
elevator system which moves through a
cold room for about two hours
this constant motion ensures optimal air
circulation helping the cooling process